This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. 2017 was a tough year. Okay, maybe that was an understatement. What he said 24 hours ago is if red, it's very serious. Should the world and more importantly, should Kim Jong-un take that literally? That's how they take that literally. This thoughtfulness isn't what shareholders are looking for and it's not what voters look at.
这里是 Hidden Brain，我是香卡·韦丹塔 (Shankar Vedanta)。2017年是艰难的一年。好吧，也许这说得太保守了。他24小时前说的话是，如果是红色，那就非常严重。世界，更重要的是，金正恩应该把这话当真吗？这就是他们当真的方式。这种深思熟虑并不是股东们想要的，也不是选民们所关注的。
That is the unraveling of an informed democracy. Where was I? Oh yeah, we're all going to die. Many Americans are angry that anger has led to sadness and a fear that the United States is falling apart. After two centuries as a beacon of democracy, many fear the ties that bind us together as a nation are starting to fray. Brexit has spurred secession talks all over the world, even in our own country.
这是一个知情民主制度的瓦解。我刚才说到哪了？哦对，我们都得死。许多美国人感到愤怒，这种愤怒带来了悲伤，以及美国正在四分五裂的恐惧。在经历了两个世纪的民主灯塔之后，许多人担心，将我们作为一个国家紧密相连的纽带开始出现裂痕。英国脱欧引发了世界各地的独立风潮，甚至在我们自己的国家也是如此。
That's what active this in the state of California want. Ever since the election of President Trump, the campaign for cow access is set. Time several hundred people face to face, it rolls using sticks and rocks as weapons. If you feel our nation is at a breaking point, today's show may provide you some solace. Historian David Maas takes the long view. In his book Democracy a Case Study, David argues that intense political conflict, to the point where it looks like a democracy is about to fail, has been with us since the country was
这就是加利福尼亚州那些活跃分子想要的。自从特朗普总统当选以来，争取科威特（注：原文应为加州独立相关词汇，此处按字面或语境翻译）准入的运动就已经确定。数百人面对面，用棍棒和石头作为武器。如果你觉得我们的国家正处于崩溃的边缘，今天的节目可能会给你带来一些慰藉。历史学家大卫·马斯（David Maas）采取了长远的眼光。在他的书《民主：一个案例研究》（Democracy a Case Study）中，大卫认为，激烈的政治冲突——甚至达到了民主似乎即将失败的程度——自这个国家诞生以来就一直伴随着我们。
born. In fact, he argues, such conflict, far from being a harbinger of doom, is actually a sign of vitality. I think we need to remember American democracy is far from perfect, but it is extraordinarily resilient and it is generated tremendous progress. Many people judge political success or failure based on whether their side wins. David uses a different metric. He says in the long term, real success and failure is about the health or sickness of democracy
事实上，他认为，这种冲突远非厄运的预兆，反而是充满活力的象征。我认为我们需要记住，美式民主远非完美，但它具有非凡的韧性，并取得了巨大的进步。许多人以自己支持的一方是否获胜来判断政治上的成功或失败。大卫则采用了不同的衡量标准。他说，从长远来看，真正的成功和失败在于民主本身的健康状况还是生病了。
itself. Does conflict strengthen our bonds, or does it destroy the fabric that holds us together? In today's episode, we'll use American history as a lens to look at how conflict can sometimes bring people together and sometimes tear them apart. So if you could, I would love to just get a level on your voice as we get started.
冲突是增强了我们的纽带，还是摧毁了维系我们的社会结构？在今天的节目中，我们将以美国历史为视角，来看看冲突有时是如何将人们凝聚在一起，有时又是如何将他们分化的。所以如果可以的话，在我们开始时，我很想了解一下你的声音状态。
David and I met for an interview on the sidelines of a conference in Colorado. My producer Tara Boylenai found a meeting room at our hotel for the interview. It wasn't quite studio quality, but it had a rustic charm to it. I started by asking David the obvious question. At a time when political conflict seems to be pulling the country apart, how can he possibly be optimistic? Certainly in the United States, conflict has been not every time, but a lot of the time
大卫和我相约在科罗拉多州的一次会议间隙进行采访。我的制作人塔拉·博伊莱奈 (Tara Boylenai) 在我们入住的酒店找了一个会议室用于采访。它虽然算不上录音室品质，但有一种质朴的魅力。我首先问了大卫一个显而易见的问题。在政治冲突似乎正在撕裂国家的时刻，他怎么可能还保持乐观？当然在美国，冲突并非每次都发生，但在很多时候……
very productive. So I could give you many examples, maybe we could talk about some of them, but really if you think about, for example, in the economic marketplace, competition, conflict is really what drives innovation, new ideas, and the same thing happens in the political sphere. So you have two parties, you have different interest groups, you have all sorts of different people trying to fight it out. And in the process, you get all sorts of good ideas
非常富有成效。因此我可以举出很多例子，也许我们可以讨论其中一些，但实际上如果你仔细想想，例如在经济市场中，竞争和冲突才是真正推动创新和新想法的动力，在政治领域也是如此。所以你有两个政党，有不同的利益集团，有各种各样的人在争取。在这个过程中，你会得到各种各样的好想法。
that are surfaced. And so conflict competition in the political marketplace is crucial. David says that what matters is not whether this conflict, but whether that conflict is constructive or destructive to democracy. If you just focus on the conflict, you might not see the real picture. To understand the effects of different kinds of conflict, I asked David to tell me about three moments in American history, where political disagreements were so intense, it seemed like the
这些想法浮出水面。因此，政治市场中的冲突与竞争是至关重要的。大卫说，重要的不是有没有这种冲突，而是这种冲突对民主是有建设性的还是破坏性的。如果你只关注冲突，你可能就看不到事情的全貌。为了解各种冲突的影响，我请大卫讲述了美国历史上的三个时刻，当时政治分歧如此剧烈，以至于国家似乎随时都会崩溃。
country might implode. In one case, as we will see, it nearly did. The first moment was just a few years after the founding of the new nation. We think of today as being an unusually bitter moment in politics. Donald Trump calls Hillary Clinton crooked Hillary, while Democrats say Trump is unfit for office, possibly crazy. But the founding fathers were happy to sling mud 2. Thomas Jefferson's supporters called John Adams, Hidious, and her mafrundedical. Adams called Alexander Hamilton, that bastard brat of a Scottish peddler. The Nazi talk was hardly the worst of it. They were deep
正如我们将看到的，在其中一个案例中，它真的差点崩溃。第一个时刻是在这个新国家建立后不久。我们认为今天是政治上异常激烈的时刻。唐纳德·特朗普称希拉里·克林顿为“骗子希拉里”，而民主党人则称特朗普不适合担任公职，甚至可能疯了。但建国先父们也很乐意互相抹黑。托马斯·杰斐逊的支持者称约翰·亚当斯为“丑陋的、雌雄同体的角色”。亚当斯称亚历山大·汉密尔顿为“苏格兰小贩的那个杂种”。纳粹式的言论还远算不上最糟糕的。他们之间存在着深刻的分歧。
disagreements about what it meant to be a country. George Washington said he was mortified that political fighting had left the country looking called ridiculous and contemptible. It did appear to many, including Washington, that the country might be falling apart. So if you look at what was going on, this new nation had just, you know,
关于成为一个国家意味着什么，存在着深刻的分歧。乔治·华盛顿曾表示，政治争斗让这个国家看起来“荒谬可笑、令人鄙视”，这让他感到羞耻。在包括华盛顿在内的许多人看来，这个国家确实似乎正在四分五裂。所以如果你看看当时的情况，这个新国家刚刚……
they declared their independence in 1776. And so, you know, they're jubilant about having won this battle, but it turns out that things sort of turn south fairly quickly. So within a few years of the formal end of the war, he starts seeing some very serious problems across the country. At the time, the new nation was not yet
他们在1776年宣布独立。因此，他们为赢得这场战斗而欢欣鼓舞，但事实证明，情况很快就急转直下。因此，在战争正式结束后的几年内，你开始看到全国上下出现一些非常严重的问题。当时，这个新国家还没有由我们的宪法管理。
governed by our constitution, but by another document known as the Articles of Confederation. And they really made the states almost all powerful. The states were sovereign. Federal government existed, but it was very weak. There was no president. There was no Supreme Court, just a Congress. And the Congress had very limited power. For example, it could spend, and it could borrow, but it couldn't tax. So it turns out that may not have been the best idea, because the government does spend, especially on the war, and it couldn't tax. So it turns out that may not have been the best idea because the government does spend, especially on the war, and it does borrow.
而是由另一份被称为《邦联条例》的文件管理。这部条例实际上赋予了各州近乎全能的权力。各州是主权的。联邦政府存在，但非常虚弱。没有总统，没有最高法院，只有国会。而且国会的权力非常有限。例如，它能支出，也能借款，但它不能征税。事实证明，这可能不是一个好主意，因为政府确实有支出，特别是在战争期间，但它却不能征税。事实证明，这可能不是一个好主意，因为政府确实有支出，特别是是在战争期间，它也举债。
But then, of course, it's not able to raise revenues. So the federal government is soon in default. They're not able to pay their creditors, and among the creditors who are most important are former soldiers, and so the soldiers aren't getting paid. So that's a serious problem. That's one thing going on. The states start putting tariffs on each other. The original idea was they were almost
但当然，随之而来的却是它无法筹集收入。因此联邦政府很快陷入债务违约。他们无法支付债权人的债务，而其中最重要的债权人是退伍老兵，所以士兵们拿不到薪水。这是一个严重的问题。这是一方面。各州开始互相征收关税。最初的想法是它们将成为一个庞大的自由贸易区，但这很快就破产了。经济陷入衰退。经济学家对它的严重程度存在争议。有些人甚至说它比大萧条还要糟糕。许多人说它没有那么严重。但无论如何，当时的人们认为这是一个相当严重的问题。
going to be a big free trade zone, but that breaks down fairly quickly. The economy falls into recession. Economists disagree about exactly how severe it was. Some say it was even worse than the Great Depression. Many say it was much less severe. But in any case, people at the time thought it was a pretty bad problem.
所以有所有这些不同的事情在发生。这就是为什么华盛顿感到难以言喻的羞愧。所以当然也有很多政治冲突，但我认为这甚至是一个更深层次的问题。事实上，他接着说，他感到难以言喻的羞愧，在我们的独立得到承认的时刻，我们在整个欧洲眼中显得荒谬而可笑。所以他的意思是，我们创立了这个国家，而它正在四分五裂。因此，正当各州。
So there are all these different things going on. And that's why Washington is mortified beyond expression. So there are certainly, there's a lot of political conflict as well, but I think it's even, it's a deeper question. In fact, he goes on and he said that he's mortified beyond expression, that at the moment of our acknowledged independence, we look ridiculous and contemptible in the eyes of all Europe. And so what he's saying is we've we've found this country and it's falling apart. So as the states are
互相争吵，我们试图弄清楚是否真的要建立一个切实可行的联邦政府时，事实证明，关于如何构建我们今天所理解的现代联邦政府的机构，各州达成某种妥协。看，最早的辩论之一是如何建立国会？小州希望国会能够代表它们，每个州一票，像特拉华州或新罕布什尔州这样的州就会这样希望。但其他州，大州则希望按比例代表制，即根据选民数量进行代表。但无论如何，当他们试图弄清楚如何建立国会时，他们想出了一个有趣的妥协，也就是我们都知道的伟大妥协。
wrangling with one another and we're trying to figure out whether to actually have a workable federal government, it turns out that the states come up with something of a compromise in terms of how to build the institutions of what today we think off as the modern federal government. So look, one of the first debates was how do you build Congress? The small states wanted a Congress that would represent them one vote per state, so a state like Delaware or New Hampshire would want that. But other states, the large states wanted proportional representation, representation according to the number of voters. But in any case, as they were trying to figure out how to set up Congress, they came up with an interesting compromise, which we all know is the great compromise,
正如你所知，他们建立众议院的组织形式将是按比例代表制。而参议院将是每个州两票。但这里特别有趣的是，我认为人们经常想到妥协。我们认为，你今天随时都会听到这种说法，“哦，我们需要妥协，我们需要在中间见面”。在中间见面是妥协的一种形式。它有时会发生。
where they set up the house of representatives, as you well know, is going to be organized by a proportional representation. And the Senate is going to be two votes per state. But what's particularly interesting about this is that I think often people think about compromise. And we think, and you hear this all the time today, oh, we need to compromise, we need to meet in the middle. Meeting in the middle is one form of compromise. It occurs sometimes.
但我认为在美国历史以及处理我所看到的这种冲突时，更常见的是你不会在中间见面。你是在做双方最好的结合。融合一个想法的最好部分和另一个想法的最好部分。所以你看到的是，小州得到了他们想要的，大州也得到了他们想要的。所以不是在中间见面。
But I think even more common, I think, in American history and dealing with the kind of conflict that I see is that you don't meet in the middle. You do sort of the best of both. The best of one idea and the best of another. So what you see is the small states got what they wanted and the large states got what they wanted. So instead of meeting in the middle
或者平分秋色，他们两全其美。让华盛顿感到羞耻的历史时刻也带来了一种延续了两个多世纪的政府模式。冲突虽然痛苦，但富有成效。[“钢琴音乐”] 大约100年后，这个年轻的国家再次受到考验，这一次是在亚伯拉罕·林肯当选之后。
or splitting the difference, they did both. So the historical moment that mortified Washington also resulted in a model of government that has endured for more than two centuries. The conflict was painful, but productive. ["Piano music"] Nearly 100 years later, the new nation was tested again, this time, after the election of Abraham Lincoln.
任凭后果如何，不论波托马克河是否被人类的鲜血染成深红。宾夕法尼亚大道是否被残破的尸体铺满十英寻深。不论自由的最后一点痕迹是否从美洲大陆的表面被抹去，南方也绝不接受林肯就职那样奇耻大辱和贬低。亚特兰大的一家报纸表达了当时国许多人的感受。南方各州开始脱离联邦。
Let the consequences be what they may, whether the Potomac is crimson in human gore. In Pennsylvania, Avenue was paved 10 fathoms in depth with mangled bodies. Whether the last vestige of liberty is swept from the face of the American continent, the south will never submit to such humiliation and degradation as the inauguration of Abraham Lincoln. An Atlanta newspaper expressed what many were feeling in the country at the time. Southern states were starting to succeed.
那是内战前夕。虽然内战结束了奴役制度，但大卫仍然认为这一历史时刻是破坏性冲突的一个例子。那是因为冲突不是通过民主进程解决的，而是通过美国历史上最血腥的战争解决的。当你审视富有成效的冲突时，你会发现，尽管双方在某些问题或麻烦上激烈争论，但他们确实有共同点，而你一次又一次看到的是，美国人深信。
It was the eve of the Civil War. While the Civil War brought slavery to an end, David still thinks of this moment as an example of destructive conflict. That's because the conflict wasn't resolved through the democratic process, but through the bloodiest war in American history. When you look at productive conflict, what you see is that although the two sides disagree vehemently about some issue or problem, they do have something in common and what you see again and again is Americans have believed deeply in
他们的政治制度和民主，这就像是一种黏合剂，他们对民主的信仰，对民主的承诺，这就是将他们维系在一起的黏合剂。你在18世纪50年代以及通往1860年并于1861年爆发的战争中看到的是，这种黏合剂已经开始崩解。所以发生的情况是，从某种意义上说，南方人，那些支持分裂的人，他们更执着于奴隶制这一制度。
their political system and their democracy and that's kind of the glue, their faith in the democracy, their commitment to it, that's kind of the glue that holds them together. What you see in the 1850s and leading up into 1860 in the war beginning in 1861 is that glue has begun to break down. And so what happens is that in a sense, the southerners, those who are going to a favor a succession, they're more committed to the institution of slavery
以及它所代表的一切，以及他们作为奴隶主的身份和参与奴隶社会的身份，他们对这一点的执着，实际上超过了对国家民主的执着。所以当林肯当选时，他在1860年11月的选举中明确获胜。
and all that it represents and their identity as slave owners and participating in a slave society, they're so committed to that, that they actually are more committed to that than to the national democracy. And so when Lincoln is elected, and he clearly wins the election in November 1860,
毫无疑问，没有非法的投票，也没有其他国家的干涉，或者任何这些问题。他赢得了选举，他赢得了多数选票和普选票，并在选举人团中赢得了绝对多数。但他反对奴隶制的扩张。有趣的是，他并不反对奴隶制本身。他当时并没有呼吁废除奴隶制。
there's no question about illegal votes or another country intervening or any of these questions. He wins the election, he wins a plurality of the votes and he wins of the popular vote, and he wins a clear majority in the electoral college. But he opposes the expansion of slavery. Interestingly, he didn't oppose slavery per se. He wasn't calling for abolition at that point,
但他不想看到奴隶制扩张。这是一个极具争议的问题。许多南方人认为，维持奴隶制的唯一途径就是让它继续扩张，以维持自由州和蓄奴州之间的政治平衡，他们实在无法容忍美国总统反对奴隶制扩张的想法。因此，尽管他当选了，而且我认为他们承认他是堂堂正正当选的，但他们就是无法接受他担任总统。
but he didn't want to see slavery expand. And that was a very controversial issue. And many southerners who believed that the only way to maintain slavery was for it to continue to expand, to maintain political balance between free states and slave states, they couldn't really tolerate the idea that the President of the United States would oppose the expansion of slavery. And so, although he was elected, and I think they recognized he was elected in a sense fair and square, they just couldn't accept him as president.
所以你看到的是，他们把一个政策问题，在这个案例中是一个整体的世界观和生活方式，围绕着奴隶制的罪恶，他们把这置于民主之上。一旦你这样做了，黏合剂就会解体。所以现在冲突升级为争吵和暴力。因此我认为这是一个重要的教训，说明我们的分歧如何能成为力量的源泉，但也可能成为难以置信的软弱之源。问题是，我们是否有把我们维系在一起的共同点？说明我们的分歧如何能成为力量的源泉，但也可能成为难以置信的软弱之源。问题是，我们是否有把我们维系在一起的共同点？
And so what you see is they're putting a policy issue, in this case, in a entire worldview and way of life, revolving around the evils of slavery, they put that ahead of the democracy. And as soon as you do that, then the glue comes apart. So now the conflict just ascends into ranker and violence. And so I think it's an important lesson of how our differences can be a source of strength, but they can also be an incredible source of weakness. And the question is, do we have something in common that's holding us together? lesson of how our differences can be a source of strength, but they can also be an incredible source of weakness. And the question is, do we have something in common that's holding us together?
在绝大多数美国历史中，答案是“有”。但在历史上的那一刻，答案不幸是“绝对没有”。我在想，当你谈论建设性和破坏性冲突之间的区别时，你所暗示的一点是否是，当人们进行建设性的冲突时，他们实际上愿意说：“我非常坚信我是对的，但我至少愿意承认这样一种可能性，即我并没有垄断真理，我愿意承认可能还有其他人拥有……”
In most of American history, the answer has been yes. At that moment in history, the answer was, unfortunately, absolutely no. I'm wondering if one of the things you are implying when you talk about the difference between productive and destructive conflict, is when people will have productive conflict, they're actually willing to say, I believe very strongly that I'm right, but I want to at least concede the possibility that I don't have a monopoly on what is right, that I'm willing to concede that maybe there are others who have something of
价值，或者历史可能会在未来20年后证明，有些事情是我不知道的。我在想，这是否可能是你所谈论的内容的含义之一，也就是建设性冲突与破坏性冲突的区别，即在建设性冲突中，人们会说，在未来的某个时候，我也有可能是错的。我认为这很对。我认为确实如此，但即使他们不认为自己可能是错的，也会有一种感觉，如果你对民主有如此坚定的信仰，你愿意付出的努力也是有限度的。
value, or it may be that history will show in the future, 20 years from now, there is something that I don't know. And I'm wondering if this is potentially one of the implications of what you're talking about, which is the difference between productive and destructive conflict, is that in productive conflict people say, there's a chance that I could be wrong sometime in the future. I think that's correct. I think that's true, but even if they don't think they could be wrong, there's a sense that if you believe in the democracy so much, there's only so far you're willing to go.
所以问题是，为了得到你想要的东西，你愿意付出多大的努力，即使你确信你是对的？所以这可能意味着你愿意接受别人的想法，但也可能意味着你确信对方是错的，但他们是另一方，他们也是民主的一部分。所以我愿意进行相当激烈的抗争，但只到一定程度为止。所以，你知道，如果你想一想另一个比喻，那就是在一个家庭里，对吧？所以一个家庭，你知道，每个家庭人们都会争吵，会争执，会不同意所有的。
So the question is, how far are you willing to go in order to get what you want, even if you're convinced that you're right? So it may be that you're willing to entertain the ideas of others, but it also may be you're sure that the other side's wrong, but they are the other side and they're part of the democracy too. So I'm willing to fight pretty hard, but only up to a point. And so, you know, if you think another analogy would be in a family, right? So a family, you know, every family people fight, they quarrel, they disagree about all
各种各样的事情。但如果家里有爱，冲突就只会适可而止。如果爱破裂了，那么实际上冲突就会撕裂这个家庭。在20世纪，这个民主制度的纽带将再次受到考验。当我们回来时，将探讨20世纪60年代的政治动荡。马丁·路德·金正在领导民权斗争。国家存在着深深的党派分歧。这是又一个危机时刻，国家似乎正在分崩离析。
sorts of things. But if there's love in the family, the conflict only goes so far. If the love breaks down, then actually the conflict can rip the family apart. In the 20th century, the bonds of that democracy would test it again. When we come back, the political upheavals of the 1960s. Martin Luther King Jr. is leading the civil rights struggle. There are deep partisan divisions in the country. It's another moment of crisis where it seems like the nation is coming apart.
三K党是一个秘密组织，在这个国家已经存在了100年。美国给黑人人民开了一张空头支票。一张退回的支票，标明资金不足。金发现，通过迅速达成共识是无法取得进步的。事实上，他发现进步来自于引发冲突。他们有一种感觉，如果我们能在伯明翰取得突破，真正打破隔离之墙，它将向整个南方，至少是顽固的南方证明，它再也无法抵抗了。
The Ku Klux Klan is a secret organization which for 100 years has been allowed to exist in this country. America has given the Negro people a bad check. A check which has come back, Mark insufficient fun. King finds that progress isn't achieved by reaching quickly for consensus. He finds, in fact, that progress comes from triggering conflict. They are a feeling that if we can get a breakthrough in Birmingham and really break down the world of segregation, it will demonstrate to the whole South, at least the hard-core South, that it can no longer resist.
首先，如果你退后一步想想，马丁·路德·金和其他领导这场运动的人所面对的是托克维尔所说的“多数人的暴政”。事实上，你知道，除了奴隶制本身，这几乎是极端之最了。当时的吉姆·克劳法将黑人和白人隔离，特别是在南方。黑人选民的选举权被剥夺得非常严重。如果你想想看，你现在代表的是一个被剥夺了选举权的黑人少数群体。它几乎没有政治权力。它几乎没有经济权力。你该怎么做才能试图改变这个系统？
First of all, just if you have to step back and think about what Martin Luther King and others who are leading this movement they're facing what Detokful called tyranny of the majority in fact, you know other than slavery itself This was about as extreme as it comes so there were Jim Crow laws that separated blacks and whites particularly in the South There were intense a disenfranchisement of black voters and so you now represent, if you think about, you represent a black minority that has been disenfranchised. It has very little political power. It has very little economic power. What do you do to try to change the system?
所以这是一个巨大的挑战。你可以想象许多回应会是：政治系统是行不通的。我们必须走到政治系统之外。我认为金最 brilhant 的地方，以及在他之前，如果你看看从20世纪初开始的漫长历史脉络——全国有色人种协进会（NAACP），都在思考我们如何才能实现变革？
So this is an enormously big challenge. And you could imagine many responses would be the political system's not going to work. We have to go outside the political system. I think what was so brilliant about King, but also before him, if you look at the long line from the early 20th century, the NAACP, was trying to think about how do we make change?
他们的想法是，我们要拥抱民主。我们要紧紧拥抱民主。我们要揭露虚伪。这里有如此美好的原则，比如“人人生而平等”和“法律的平等保护”，但现实中的做法却是这些原则遭到践踏。我们拒绝相信这张资金不足的支票，以及这个国家充满机遇的伟大时刻。所以我们来兑现这张支票，一张将赋予我们要求自由财富和正义保障的支票。
And what they thought was we're gonna embrace democracy. We're gonna hug democracy tightly. And we're gonna reveal the hypocrisy. They're these beautiful principles like all men are created equal and equal protection of the law and then there's practice where those principles are violated. We refuse to believe that our insufficient funds and the great folks of opportunity of this nation. So we've come to cash this check, a check will give us a pun demand the riches of freedom and security of justice
我认为民权运动的领导人及其先驱们所认识到的是，虚伪实际上可以成为一个加分项，而不仅仅是减分项。所以如果你能把它挑明，如果你能揭露它，如果你能把它摆在人们面前，并表明他们珍视的原则正在被践踏。这至少在某些情况下迫使人们做出选择。有时他们选错了，不幸的是，但有时他们确实站在了原则一边。所以这基本上就是马丁·路德·金试图做的。他在挑选战斗。
And I think what leaders of the civil rights movement and its aniseedans figured out is that hypocrisy is actually can be a plus not just a minus So if you can bring it out if you can expose it if you can put it in front of people and show that the principles they hold dear are being violated. That in some cases at least forces people to choose. Sometimes they choose wrong, unfortunately, but sometimes they actually side with principles. So this is basically what Martin Luther King was trying to do. He was picking battles.
他说他要追求冲突。他确实如此。他想挑选一些最具挑战性的地方进行抗议，比如阿拉巴马州的伯明翰、塞尔玛。走进去并试图挑起冲突，进行和平抗议，但他也知道对方有一些非常强硬的人，对方有一些非常残酷的警察和警长，他们会借此机会殴打抗议者，使用警犬、水炮。
He said he was going for conflict. He was. He wanted to pick some of the most challenging places to protest, Birmingham, Alabama, Selma. Go in and to try to provoke conflict, protest peacefully, but knowing that there were some pretty tough people on the other side, some pretty brutal police and sheriffs on the other side who were going to take that opportunity to beat up the protesters, use dogs, water cannons,
等等。所以他意识到，如果你能让坐在客厅里的人们看到这种暴力，并把它暴露在光天化日之下，那么这种不幸成为当时这个国家核心的虚伪——我们谈论的是平等保护，但我们并没有实行平等保护——就会暴露无遗。这就是他所做的。
and so on. So what he realized is that if you could make people in their living rooms, see this violence, and bring it out into the light of day, then suddenly this hypocrisy, which unfortunately was at the heart of the country at that point, we were talking about equal protection, but we weren't living equal protection. So this is what he did.
所以，你知道，他去了，他先去了，你知道，是在蒙哥马利，然后是伯明翰，在伯明翰，他甚至让孩子们参加，有一场儿童游行。所以那是一个极具争议的决定。塞尔玛也是，经历了一系列类似的发展。我认为如果没有电视，我想他至少在63年就已经很清楚这一点了。如果没有电视，他是绝对做不到这一点的，但有了电视，他就能去进行和平游行，和平抗议。然而，对方的反应还是来了，而且来得非常迅猛，把这种虚伪展露无遗。
And so, you know, he goes, he goes, first, you know, it's in Montgomery, but then Birmingham, in Birmingham, he even, their children, there's a children's march. So that was a very controversial decision. Selma, again, a similar set of developments. I think without television, I think he well understood this by at least 63. Without television, I don't think he could possibly have done it, but with television, he was able to go march peacefully, protest peacefully. The reaction, though, came and it came swiftly from the other side, and it put on display this hypocrisy.
并且把这种虚伪展露无遗。伯明翰和其他地方的事件大大提高了争取平等的代价，以至于没有任何城市、州或立法机构能够忽视它们。所以你再次看到的是，冲突与对民主的坚定信念之间的这种联系，尽管这种民主是多么的不完美——说不完美简直太保守了。黑人依然没有自由。100年过去了，黑人的生活依然可悲地受到隔离手铐的摧残。当你想到当时的其他一些领导人时，确实有一些人在鼓吹1861年南方观点的某种版本。
and it put on display the hypocrisy. The events in Birmingham and elsewhere have so increased the prize for equality that no city or state or legislative body can pooply to is to ignore them. So what you see once again is this link between conflict tied to this deep faith in the democracy even how imperfect I mean imperfect is an understatement. The Negro Steel is not free. 100 years later, the life of the Negro is still sadly crippled by the manacles of segregation. When you think about some of the other leaders at the time, there were certainly people who were advocating some version of what the south was saying in 1861.
有人说，看，这个系统太破碎了，有太多缺陷，根本无法修复。我们实际上必须把它摧毁。我想你所提出的观点非常深刻，那就是金将自己包裹在国旗之中。他将自己包裹在美洲民主的理想之中，这可能正是使冲突具有建设性的原因。所以，看，这就是他所做的。有很多事情是他关心的，
There were people who were saying, look, the system is so broken, it is so faulty that there is no fixing it. We actually have to break it down. And I think the point that you're making is really well made, which is that King wrapped himself in the flag. He wrapped himself in this ideal of the American democracy, and that potentially is what made the conflict productive. So look, that's what he did. There were a lot of things he was concerned about,
但他却说，让我们秉持这些原则，看看我们是否真的能践行它们。我认为我们需要记住，美式民主远非完美，但它具有非凡的韧性，并取得了巨大的进步——经济进步、社会进步、政治进步，比我们所有人希望的要慢得多。但是，天哪，事情可能会变得非常糟糕，我们所有人都知道这一点。所以问题是，你能继续取得进步吗？那么，这些历史比喻中哪一个最能描述美国当前的时刻？
but he said, let's take these principles and actually try to see if we can all live by them. I think we need to remember American democracy is far from perfect, but it is extraordinarily resilient and it has generated tremendous progress, economic progress, social progress, political, a lot slower than we'd all like. But, boy, things can go very badly and we all know that. And so the question is, can you continue to make progress? So which of these historical analogies describes the current moment in the United States?
我们是处于民主新篇章的边缘？还是处于分道扬镳的边缘？我问了大卫最近发生的一系列引发人们对我们民主健康状况担忧的发展。他仍然在质疑贝拉克·奥巴马总统出生证明的真实性。很简单。我有人在调查此事。我们正在提出罢免特朗普总统的弹劾条款。鉴于宪政危机的严重性，病毒没有任何理由。
Are we on the brink of a new chapter in our democracy? Or on the brink of divorce? I asked David about a number of more recent developments that raised troubling signals about the health of our democracy. He's still questioning the authenticity of President Barack Obama's birth certificate. Very simple. I have people looking into it. We are introducing articles from impeachment to remove President Trump from office. Given the magnitude of the Constitution crisis, there's no reason for the virus.
这不是基于任何真正的法律理论。这相当于国会版的任性儿童在发脾气，因为他们的队伍输了。这些现代冲突是例行公事吗？还是有什么改变了？我认为两者皆有。我的意思是，这取决于你希望如何进行对比。
This is not based on any real theories of law. This is the congressional equivalent of petulant children throwing a temperate tantrum because their team lost. Are these modern conflicts business as usual? Or has something changed? I think both. I mean, it depends what you want the comparison to be.
我认为与20世纪的大部分时间相比，我们现在更加党派化了。我们今天的党派化程度达到了很长时间以来的最高点。但我必须说，如果你回顾19世纪，我们今天更加党派化了，达到了很长时间以来的最高点。但我必须说，如果你回顾19世纪，那里存在着强烈的裂痕，非常强大的裂痕。在某个时刻，这当然导致了内战。但在大部分时间里，这些裂痕实际上并没有导致任何类似暴力的事件。
I think that relative to much of the 20th century, we've been more partisan. We're more partisan today than in a long time. But I have to say, if you look back in the 19th century, we've been more partisan, we're more partisan today than in a long time. But I have to say, if you look back in the 19th century, there were strong divisions, very powerful divisions. At one moment, that, of course, led to the Civil War. But in most of the time, those divisions actually did not lead anything like violence.
事实上，它们经常带来非常富有成效的冲突。所以我不认为这个问题，我不认为正确的问题是是否存在过多的冲突。再次强调，我认为冲突，特别是如果它保持在政治领域内，是一件非常好的事情。它能产生好想法。问题是，我们有什么共同点？我认为这才是真正的关键，我们必须扪心自问，不是如何压制冲突，而是如何提升我们的共同点。所以我们没有共同的民族血统，我们没有共同的宗教信仰。
In fact, they often led to very productive conflicts. So I don't think the question, I don't think the right question is there too much conflict. Again, I think conflict, especially if it stays in the political realm, is a very good thing. It generates good ideas. The question is, what do we have in common? I think that's really, we have to ask ourselves, not how do we suppress conflict, but how do we elevate what we have in common. So we don't have a common ethnic origin, we don't have a common religion.
这个国家与许多其他国家非常不同。我们有来自各方的人。从一开始，我们拥有的就是，我希望，是对小写的“d”（而不是党派，而是系统）民主的共同信仰。民主的，或者你可以称之为小写“r”的共和政体。事实上，本杰明·富兰克林，这个国家产生过的最伟大的头脑之一，早在1776年的大陆会议上，就在通过《独立宣言》几小时后，要求一个由约翰·亚当斯、托马斯·杰斐逊和本·富兰克林等举足轻重的人物组成的强有力小组，为美利坚合众国设计一个国徽，即大国玺，一个双面徽标。他们想为这个刚成立的新国家制作一些宣传营销材料。
This country is very different from many others. We have people coming from all over. What we've had from the beginning is a, is a, is a, I hope, is a common faith in smallty, not the party, but the system. Democratic, or you can call it small-ar, Republican governance. And this actually Benjamin Franklin, one of the greatest minds this country ever produced, back in 1776, the continental Congress, just hours after it adopted the Declaration of Independence, it asked a very powerful heavy wake group of people, John Adams, Thomas Jefferson, and Ben Franklin, to develop a seal for the United States of America, the great seal, a two-sided emblem. They wanted some marketing materials for this new country.
他们刚刚成立。无论如何，这三个人提出了一个设计，但国会不喜欢。他们拒绝了。他们又提出了另一个设计。但在这一过程中，富兰克林提出了三个国会确实喜欢的词。这三个拉丁词就是：E Pluribus Unum（合众为一）。他借用这个词，不是来自哪位伟大的罗马思想家，而是来自他喜欢的一本杂志，叫做。
They just formed. And anyway, these three come up with a design, and Congress doesn't like it. They rejected. They come up with another design. But Franklin, in that process, came up with three words that Congress did like. And those three words were Latin words, E. Pluribus Unum. He took it from a, he took those words, not from a great Roman thinker, but rather from a magazine he liked called,
《绅士杂志》。那是一本文学杂志，封面上有这样几个字：E Pluribus Unum，合众为一。这本杂志想要表达的意思是，从许多文学作品中，他们汇集了许多文学作品的碎片，从许多文学作品的碎片中，汇成了一本杂志。他将其视为从许多州和人民中，汇成一个国家，我想他很早就明白。
Gentleman's magazine. It was a literary magazine, and on the cover were these words, E. Pluribus Unum, out of many one. And what they were trying to say in the magazine was out of many literary works, they brought together many fragments of literary works, out of many fragments of literary works, one magazine. What he saw it as out of many states and peoples, one nation, and I think what he understood
多样性和差异为这个国家创造了巨大的优势。但究竟是什么将创造这种团结呢？那将是我们的信仰，我们对民主自治的共同信仰，或者他会称之为共和自治。因此我认为这极其重要，所以当我们审视冲突时，试图压制冲突可能是一种徒劳的尝试，问题是我们是否有足够的共同点将它维系在一起？政治学家注意到，两党在意识形态上正变得越来越一致。换句话说，共和党人比过去更加保守。
really very early was that diversity, difference, created great strengths for the country. But what was going to create that unity? It was going to be our belief, our common belief in democratic self-governance, or he would have called it Republican self-governance. And so I think that that's just immensely important so as we look at conflict I think it's maybe a fool's errand to try to suppress conflict the question is do we have enough in common to hold it together political scientists have noticed that both parties are becoming more ideologically consistent in other words Republicans are more conservative
而民主党人则比过去更加自由。我问大卫，这种极化是否会导致破坏性的冲突。听着，我们不知道。所以我想谨慎一些。历史，我是一个历史学家，我回顾过去。我不擅长预测未来，我想我们谁都不擅长。所以我们不知道这种类型的冲突本身是否危险。我想我并不确信它是。我认为一个大得多的担忧是，如果你看看盖洛普定期询问的一个问题，如果你问，你是否有信心让你的同胞作为我们民主的一部分做出决定？
and Democrats are more liberal than they used to be. I asked David if this kind of polarization might be leading to destructive conflict. Look, we don't know. So I want to be careful. History, I'm a historian, I look backwards. I'm not so good at predicting the future, and I think none of us are. So we don't know if this type of conflict is itself dangerous. I guess I'm not convinced that it is. I think a much bigger concern, and if you look at, for example, Gallup asked this question on a regular basis, if you asked, do you have confidence in your fellow Americans to make decisions as part of our democracy?
实际上，这个数字一直在急剧下降。表示对同胞几乎没有或根本没有信心的人数急剧增加，从20世纪70年代初的约15%上升到今天的约43%。这是一个很大的数字。我必须说，比起意识形态的一致性等问题，我更担心这些数字。我认为问题在于，你对周围的人是否还有一些信仰？
Actually, that number has been falling quite dramatically. And the number who say that they have little or no confidence in their fellow Americans has increased sharply from about 15% in the early 1970s to about 43% today. Those are big numbers. I have to say, I worry much more about those numbers than ideological conformity and so on. I think the question is, do you have some faith in those around you?
即使你与他们产生尖锐的分歧，你是否相信这个系统？当失败时，你是否愿意接受它？当你失败时，你是否也会受到一定程度的尊重？你知道，当我们思考赢和输时，我们必须优雅地接受失败，我们也必须优雅地赢得胜利。也许我们只是需要小心，不要让。
Even if you disagree with them sharply, do you believe in the system? Are you willing when you lose to accept it? And are you going to be treated with some degree of respect when you lose as well? You know, as we think about winning and losing, we have to lose with grace and we have to win with grace as well. And maybe we just have to be careful not to let
输赢本身变成了一种价值。当我与大卫交谈时，我想起了一个恶劣的笑话。一个人从百层高楼的顶端摔下来。在下坠的过程中，他经过了第20层，并对自己说：“嗯，到目前为止一切似乎都挺顺利的。”大卫对历史的看法是美国是有韧性的。我们经历过许多挫折和危机，但没有哪一次被证明是致命的。当我们回来时，我要问大卫，我们如何才能知道我们当前的时刻只是那些虚惊一场之一，还是那个即将……摔得粉碎的家伙的例子。啪嗒。啪嗒。
the winning and losing become a value of its own. As I was talking to David, I thought of a wicked joke. A man falls off the top of a hundred-story building. As he's falling, he passes the 20th floor and he tells himself, well, everything seems to be going pretty well so far. David's take on history is that the United States is resilient. We've had a lot of setbacks and crises and none of them has proved fatal. When we come back, I'm going to ask David how we can know if our present moment is just one of those false alarms, or whether it's an example of that guy who's about to go... splatter. Splat.
社会科学家在研究现象时会谈到两类问题。他们谈到假阳性和假阴性的事情。所以假阳性是那些看起来像警报的事情，如果你对它们给予太多关注，你就会钻进各种各样的小胡同里去追查各种小事，而其中大多数最终都不会有什么结果。如果你忽视了假阴性，它们就是你所忽略的那些最终被证明是灾难性的事情。我在想，当你思考漫长的历史长河时，很显然。
Social scientists talk about two sets of problems when you're looking at phenomena. They talk about things that are false positives and things that are false negatives. So the false positives are things that look like alarm bells and if you pay too much attention to them, you will chase all sorts of little things down rabbit holes and most of them will come to nothing. If you ignore the false negatives, they are the things that you miss that actually turn out to be catastrophic. And I'm wondering as you are thinking about the long sweep of history, it's clear there
有许多、许多、许多假阳性的例子，你某种程度上说事情看起来要散架了，事情看起来要崩溃了，但它们并没有。因此，你得出的结论是这个国家是有韧性的。但我在想，这种对我们韧性的信仰会不会掩盖这样一个事实：有时实际上我们可能正处于危险之中。换句话说，只有在事后诸葛亮的情况下，你才知道某件事结果是好是坏，而在当时，你怎么知道它会朝哪个方向发展？
have been many, many, many examples of false positives, where you sort of said things look like they're coming apart, things look like they're falling apart, and they haven't. And the case you make as a result is that the country is resilient. But I'm wondering if this belief in our resilience can hide the fact that sometimes actually we might be at risk. In other words, it's only in hindsight that you know that a certain thing turned out well or badly, in the moment, how do you know which way it's going to go?
没错。所以你说过，人们看到美洲民主崩溃已经很长很长时间了，当詹姆斯·麦迪逊当选时，康涅狄格州一份狂热的联邦党人报纸曾说，这个国家正在迅速走向暴政和毁灭的宽阔道路上。所以这些事情以前发生过。正如你所说，批评者通常是错的。但在某个时刻，他们没有错，对吧，在内战前夕。我们不能仅仅因为很多很多次人们说民主正在失败而很多很多次他们都错了，就感到安慰。因为如果我们这样做，如果这一次他们是对的呢？
Right. So you said that people have been seeing the collapse of American democracy for a very, very long time, when James Madison was elected, a fiercely Federalist newspaper in Connecticut said that the country was fast on the broad road to despotism and ruin. So these things have happened before. And the critics, as you say, the critics are usually wrong. In one moment, they weren't, right, in the lead up to the Civil War. We can't just take comfort in the fact that many, many times people have said democracy was failing and many, many times they were wrong. Because if we do that, what if this is one of the times when they're right?
所以你在问这个问题，你如何分辨区别？我认为你需要审视的是，民主的文化是否足够强大，能够将我们维系在一起？这就是我不断在问的问题。你怎么知道？你需要审视你的政客，审视你那一边同意你观点的政客。你是否看到他们曾将民主置于第二位？他们这样做的频率如何？所以我会把这个决定留给听众去做出。
So you're asking the question, how can you tell the difference? I think you need to look at, is the culture of democracy strong enough to hold us together? That's the question I keep asking. How do you know? You need to look at your politicians, look at the ones on your side who agree with you. And do you see them ever putting democracy in second place? And how often do they do it? So I'll leave it to listeners to make that decision.
我猜你可以找到其中的一些例子，你也可以在历史中找到例子。这种情况越严重，它就越危险。我认为，在一个民主国家中，保持高度警惕是件好事。也就是说，要认为，哦，我们的系统可能有病。因为当你认为它可能有病时，你就会采取一些行动去试图修复它。你会发现，正是在政治改革的时刻，你确实拥有了几乎像一所国家公民课一样的经历。
My guess is you can find some examples of that and you can find examples in history. The more severe that becomes, the more dangerous it becomes. It's good, I think, in a democracy to be hyper-contracts. That is, to think that, oh, our system might be sick. Because when you think it might be sick, you start to take some action to try to fix it. And you see that it's in moments of political reform that you do have, almost like a national civics class.
你确实让人门谈论民主，思考原则，正如我们之前讨论过的民权运动、投票权运动，一直通向1965年的《投票权法案》。那真是一个这样的时代。它就像是一堂国家公民课。所以人们正在思考这些问题，平等保护究竟意味着什么？
You do get people talking about democracy, thinking about principles, the civil rights movement, voting rights movement that we talked about before and leading up to the 1965 Voting Rights Act. That was such a time. It was like a national civics class. And so where people were thinking about these, what does equal protection mean?
确实有人在谈论民主，思考各种原则，比如我们之前讨论过的民权运动、投票权运动，以及通往1965年《投票权法案》的历程。那真是一个特殊的时期，就像一堂全国性的公民教育课。人们当时都在思考这些问题：平等保护到底意味着什么？
Are we following it? Are we not following it? So we need to think about that. And if we can maybe just get away a little bit from only talking about should taxes be higher low, should government be bigger, small? Should guns be protected this way or not protected? Or so on?
我们在遵循它吗？我们没有遵循它吗？所以我们需要考虑这一点。如果我们能稍微摆脱只讨论税收应该高还是低、政府应该庞大还是精简的局面呢？枪支应该以这种方式受到保护还是不应该受到保护？诸如此类？
All those fights are important fights, extremely important. But we can't only fight about that. We need to think about sort of the broader pillars of government and make sure we understand them and fight about that. We need to think about sort of the broader pillars of government and make sure we understand them and make sure we retain our commitment to them. One of the other factors you identify that's different about partisanship today from partisanship in the past is that you say partisanship in the past was more
所有这些争斗都是重要的争斗，极其重要。但我们不能只为这些争斗。我们需要思考政府更广泛的支柱，确保我们理解它们并为之争斗。我们需要思考政府更广泛的支柱，确保我们理解它们，并确保我们保持对它们的承诺。你指出的当今党派性与过去党派性不同的另一个因素是，你认为过去的党派性更偏向于
exuberant, that things were more cynical today rather than exuberant. What do you mean by exuberant partisanship and how could we bring that back? One of the things I write about in the book is particularly in the conclusion is this is what appears to be a decline in this culture of democracy. And one element of that actually goes back a very long way. It's not just recent. So as you say, I think if you go back into the 19th century, partisanship was extremely, extremely strong. But there was a life in it, an excitement.
充满活力，现在的局势与其说是充满活力，不如说是愤世嫉俗。你所说的充满活力的党派性是什么意思，我们又该如何恢复它？我在书中写到的其中一件事，特别是在结论部分，就是这似乎是民主文化的一种衰落。而其中的一个要素实际上可以追溯到很久以前。它不仅仅是最近才出现的。正如你所说，我认为如果你追溯到19世纪，党派性非常非常强烈。但其中蕴含着生命力，一种兴奋感。
You use the word exuberance, I think that's a good one. And that came out, for example, beautifully on election day. Election day was a celebration, it was a party. It was completely different from election day today. What do I mean by that? Well, back then, actually, voting was public. So this was before the secret ballot. You would go and cast a ballot.
你用了“活力”这个词，我认为这是一个很好的词。例如，这在选举日得到了完美的体现。选举日是一个庆祝活动，是一个派对。它与今天的选举日完全不同。我这是什么意思？嗯，当时实际上投票是公开的。所以在无记名投票出现之前。你会去投下一票。
Your ballot usually had a color. It might be pink. It might be blue. And it would reflect what party you were voting for. Everyone could see when you put the ballot in. And there were a lot of people around you. In fact, usually at your voting place, there was a celebration going on.
你的选票通常有一种颜色。可能是粉红色的。可能是蓝色的。它反映了你投的是哪个党派。每个人都能看到你把选票放进去的时候。你周围有很多人。事实上，通常在你的投票点，都会有一场庆祝活动。
There was a lot of debating. There was a lot of drinking. There was a lot of fighting. There was a celebration going on, there was a lot of debating, there was a lot of drinking, there was a lot of fighting, there was a lot going on. And some people were actually afraid to go vote because it was such a raucous environment. But overall, the voting rates were up at 70, 75, 80 percent, so very high voting rates, much higher than we have today. So there was this celebratory atmosphere that was going on at every election day. And part of that was something we wouldn't want to repeat.
有很多辩论。有很多饮酒。有很多争斗。有一场庆祝活动在进行，有很多辩论，有很多饮酒，有很多争斗，有很多事情在发生。有些人实际上害怕去投票，因为环境太喧闹了。但总体而言，投票率高达70%、75%、80%，投票率非常高，比我们今天要高得多。因此，每次选举日都会出现这种庆祝的气氛。其中一部分是我们不想重复的。
So why were ballots so public? Why was voting so public? Well part of it was political machines wanted to be able to pay people off to vote for their party. And you couldn't really pay people off if you couldn't see how they were going to vote. So if you're going to pay them a dollar to vote this way or that, you had to make sure you knew how they're actually going to vote. So if you're going to pay them a dollar to vote this way or that, you had to make sure you knew how they're actually going to vote. So you had to have someone at the polling place watch them put the vote in. So there was a downside. There was a corruption associated
那么为什么选票这么公开？为什么投票这么公开？嗯，部分原因是政治机器希望能够付钱给人们让他们投票支持他们的党派。如果你看不到他们将如何投票，你就无法真正付钱给人们。所以如果你要付给他们一美元让他们这样或那样投票，你必须确保你知道他们实际上将如何投票。因此，如果你要付给他们一美元让他们这样或那样投票，你必须确保你知道他们实际上将如何投票。所以你必须让投票站的某个人看着他们把选票投进去。所以这有一个缺点。存在与此相关的腐败
with this old system. But unfortunately when we fix that, we ended up taking the life out of voting. And now most people go, they vote, they vote in a private booth and they make their decision, they walk out, they may be by a a brownie to bake sale or something. And that's about it. There's not really much engagement, there's certainly not a lot of debating, there's not a lot of drinking, and there's maybe fortunately not a lot of fighting, physical fighting. But there is a question, could we have a little bit more of that celebratory atmosphere? Could election day be a holiday?
伴随着这个旧系统。但不幸的是，当我们修复它时，我们最终剥夺了投票的生命力。现在大多数人去投票，他们在私人投票间投票，做出决定，然后走出去，他们可能会顺便买个布朗尼蛋糕或类似的东西。仅此而已。没有太多的参与，肯定没有太多的辩论，没有太多的饮酒，而且可能幸运的是没有太多的打架，肉搏战。但有一个问题，我们能否拥有多一点这种庆祝的气氛？选举日能成为一个节日吗？
Could it be more of a celebration? And what you'd see is a lot more people engaged in the democracy and it's an important moment. So we lost that, we got something in return, we got a cleaner electoral system, I wouldn't want to give that up, but boy we lost something in the process. When I look at the present moment just in the last few months, it feels like I've seen numerous pictures of liberals and Democrats holding up signs to Donald Trump saying not my president. He's not my president.
它能更像是一个庆祝活动吗？你会看到更多的人参与到民主中来，这是一个重要的时刻。所以我们失去了这一点，我们得到了回报，我们得到了一个更清洁的选举系统，我不想放弃这一点，但天哪，我们在过程中失去了某些东西。当我审视当下，就在过去的几个月里，我觉得我看到了无数的自由派和民主党人举着牌子对唐纳德·特朗普说“这不是我的总统”。他不是我的总统。
Deeply unhappy about how the election turned out, but not just unhappy to the point of saying he's not a legitimate president. When you look at the conflict we're having right now about where the Russia interfered with the presidential election, there residual division among Republicans is this, are we supposed to be defending the president and approaching this from a partisan point of view, or are we supposed to be thinking about this as Americans, worried about foreign power trying to influence our democracy? I think both of those are pretty clear examples that lots of people are placing party before country.
对选举结果深感不满，但不仅是不满到说他不是合法总统的程度。当你审视我们目前关于俄罗斯是否干涉总统选举的冲突时，共和党人之间残留的分歧是：我们到底是应该捍卫总统并从党派的角度来看待这个问题，还是应该像美国人一样思考，担心外国势力试图影响我们的民主？我认为这两个都是非常明显的例子，许多人将党派置于国家之上。
I think it depends how far it goes. So certainly, you gave the example of many people are out there saying, front isn't my president. You know, the same was true of Barack Obama that many people didn't think he was a legitimate president. I think the question, though, is to what extent are you then willing to violate the law because you think there is no law? And so I think that would be crossing a barrier.
我认为这取决于它走得多远。当然，你举了一个例子，很多人都在外面说，现任不是我的总统。你知道，巴拉克·奥巴马也是如此，许多人不认为他是合法总统。不过，我认为问题在于，你在多大程度上愿意违法，因为你认为没有法律？因此，我认为那将是越过一条界限。
And so the truth is you can disagree with, for example, either president's executive orders and you can take them to court. The question is, what do you do if you lose in court? And what do you do is court kind of the proper remedy? I would say if you believe in the democracy, it is. And sometimes you lose. And sometimes you lose for a long time.
所以事实是，你可以不同意例如任何一位总统的行政命令，你可以把他们告上法庭。问题是，如果你在法庭上输了怎么办？你该怎么办？法庭算是一种恰当的补救措施吗？我会说，如果你相信民主，它就是。有时你会输。有时你会输很长时间。
So those who lose need to try to respect the process, fight as hard as they can. I'm not trying to say not to fight as hard as they can. The question is, do you legally respect the process? Those who hold up and sign and saying, the president's not my president, I think they're exercising their first amendment rights. I have to say that doesn't cause me grave concern.
所以那些失败的人需要努力尊重这个过程，尽最大努力去抗争。我并不是说不要尽最大努力去抗争。问题是，你是否在法律上尊重这个过程？那些举着牌子说“这位总统不是我的总统”的人，我认为他们在行使第一修正案赋予的权利。我必须说，这并没有引起我的严重关切。
The question is, do you then recognize the political process as itself as legitimate? I think so far, mostly I think the answer has been yes. So I'm not so worried about the signs. I do get concerned though about this atrophy. If you look at our culture of democracy, I've given you one piece of data from a Gallup poll, I could give you some others. I think our culture of democracy has weakened.
问题是，你是否随后承认政治过程本身是合法的？我想目前为止，大部分人我的回答是肯定的。所以我并不是那么担心这些牌子。不过，我确实对这种萎缩感到担忧。如果你看看我们的民主文化，我从盖洛普民意测验中给你提供了一条数据，我还可以给你提供其他数据。我认为我们的民主文化已经削弱了。
Maybe that's a little bit part of the reason why people are sometimes holding up those signs. But again, if that glue is coming apart, then I start to worry that, are we going to get the best from Colomé and the best from Colom column B like we did at the Constitutional Convention and so many other times after that? Or are we going to get paralyzed and be unable to act? Or are we going to find a kind of tyranny of the majority? So these are all possible outcomes in our system of government. What I think we need to come to respect is the power of productive tension,
也许这也是人们有时举起这些牌子的部分原因。但是话说回来，如果这种凝聚力正在瓦解，那么我开始担心，我们是否会从A栏和B栏中获得最好的结果，就像我们在制宪会议和之后许多次那样？还是我们会陷入瘫痪，无法采取行动？或者我们会发现某种多数人的暴政？这些都是我们政府体制中可能的结局。我认为我们需要开始尊重的是富有成效的紧张关系的力量，
of productive conflict, and how important it is in a sense to be ambidextrous as citizens. On the one hand, we need to be fighting as hard as we can peacefully, to get our views, to keep pushing even, you know, when we lose, we keep pushing and pushing. But at the same time, on the other hand, we need to respect our democracy, and we need to respect it and show it great reverence. David, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me.
富有成效的冲突的力量，以及作为公民做到左右逢源是多么重要。一方面，我们需要尽最大努力和平抗争，表达我们的观点，不断推动，即使在我们失败时，我们也继续推动。但与此同时，另一方面，我们需要尊重我们的民主，我们需要尊重它并对它表现出极大的敬意。大卫，感谢你今天加入我们的“隐藏的大脑”。非常感谢邀请我。
David Moss is the author of Democracy, a case study. He's a historian at Harvard University. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Maggie Pennman and Tara Boyle. Our team includes Raina Cohen, René Clare, Parth Shah and Jenny Schmidt. Special thanks this week to Jared Walker at Oregon Public Broadcasting. For more Hidden Brain you can follow us on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram and listen for my stories on Morning Edition. Our unsung heroes this week are the thousands of volunteers at polling stations who help people exercise their democratic rights.
大卫·莫斯是《民主：一个案例研究》的作者。他是哈佛大学的历史学家。本期“隐藏的大脑”由玛吉·彭曼和塔拉·博伊尔制作。我们的团队包括雷娜·科恩、勒内·克莱尔、帕特·沙阿和珍妮·施密特。本周特别感谢俄勒冈公共广播公司的贾里德·沃尔克。欲了解更多“隐藏的大脑”节目，您可以在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上关注我们，并收听我在“早间版”上的报道。我们本周的无名英雄是投票站的数千名志愿者，他们帮助人们行使民主权利。
These are tough and unpaid jobs, but if you ever want to find evidence that many Americans care about their democracy, all you need to do is hang out with some of these volunteers. Shows like ours couldn't function without a free and fair democracy, and we are grateful to these volunteers. If you like this episode, please tell a friend about it. Also, you might want to remind that friend to show up on Election Day and vote. I'm Shankar Vidantum, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这些都是艰苦且没有报酬的工作，但如果你想找到证据证明许多美国人关心他们的民主，你所需要做的就是和其中一些志愿者待在一起。像我们这样的节目如果没有自由公正的民主就无法运转，我们感谢这些志愿者。如果你喜欢这一集，请告诉你的朋友。此外，你可能想提醒那位朋友在选举日出现并投票。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。本集节目尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。